for me my boxes are actually the biggest
indicator of when I should do laundry
right uh because it's not when I run out
what do you mean like oh this one's got
a job okay okay because like like we
said we have a tier list of boxes the
ones that you prefer one day right huh
One A Day right yeah I do want a day
yeah yeah we will do one a day I'm not
an animal I've met people who do who you
know a little I'd say a little too much
yeah like I'm not disgusting I have I
have stands okay I understand we have
hygiene standards here but so it goes in
order of newest to oldest ride the ones
I prefer wearing so obviously the newest
ones are going to be the most
comfortable you can buy the same pair of
boxes every time kite I mean see now
it's just it's already Anarchy it's it's
like when you buy like the Uniqlo or the
h m branded boxes they're all the
[ __ ] same you know they're all the
same standards I haven't gone to like
the higher [ __ ] tier s tier [ __ ]
Calvin Klein [ __ ] I don't like Calvin
Klein I literally really like just
because they're just super comfortable
and like okay but you just don't
understand I have a [ __ ] massive ass
and like the only things that can fit
comfortably are like Calvin I mean I
don't know how you're that dummy thing
it's like the ones in Japan are like
literally the best promotion for Calvin
Klein bro the ones that you don't tell
me you're trying to put on these boxes
stop it from clapping they keep them in
place without without chafing the [ __ ]
out of me because Japanese boxes are
made for like I swear 2D people yeah
yeah and it's like I put these things on
and it's like my balls cannot breathe
immediately
no so like I mean I don't have that
issue I have the issue of I have I have
the issue of it goes for you it goes It
goes in three tiers it goes in high tier
mid-tier low tier High tiers High tears
are the new boxes they're like nice and
crisp and nice and clean they've only
had a few washers it feels good it feels
like it feels like you're it feels like
your balls are like nice you know like
they're nice and cup they're like stable
and then you've got like the mid-tier
boxes these are like a few months old
the Fabric's starting to wear a bit and
you're like okay I can get away with
wearing these it's not the it's not the
best box of feel but I can make do yeah
and then when I know I need to do my
washing is when I get to the [ __ ] low
tier boxes the ones I technically should
really think about throwing out you know
like the elasticity is just like kind of
losing its like grip you know it's it's
kind of it's like hanging halfway down
yeah yeah yeah yeah right it's kind of
hanging off and and you're like I should
probably throw these away yeah but if I
did I would get to a point where I would
get to a day where I had no boxes to
wear so that's how when I get to my low
tier boxes that's how that's when I
that's when I know I need to do the
washing wait how many boxes do you own
like roughly like just enough to last
you a week or what by 12 maybe yeah yeah
because I was about to say like I have
enough to last me like at least two
weeks maybe like a week and a half it
depends some I think because we've been
traveling so often now sometimes I just
misplace them I can last about a week
and a half but I get to my low tears
after a week and that's that's how I
know that's how I know because I never
because if I didn't have my low tears
I'd just get to a week and I'm like [ __ ]
I I'm gonna be discussing that why would
you not just replace your low tier stuff
with just some brand new pair of boxes I
don't know sometimes it's just it's just
routine I I like for me I subconsciously
know I need to do the washing and it
actually gives me a reason to do the
washing because I don't want to wear my
low tier boxes but if I just add High
tier boxes I'd be like [ __ ] well I just
forget to do the washing because because
you know you can get away with wearing a
t-shirt again a day or two you know you
can get away with wearing trousers you
can't get away of wearing the same boxes
every day you know how often do you do
the washing
like once a week yeah once a week or
maybe once or twice a week for me he's
late I hate doing washing so I I will do
anything I can to delay doing the work
that's my favorite part God's uh like
very responsible but also can't just you
could just doesn't do chores like you
can tell yeah like is always late to
stuff and he doesn't do his chores I
hate doing who likes doing chores I like
doing laundry I like doing laundry so
when you get that crisp fresh laundry
it's pretty when you pull it out of the
washing machine it's like warm and fresh
and it smells good you get the Fabrics
off and everything because to me I have
I have a routine that I like doing every
day and if there's something that I that
I need to do that breaks that routine
which is normally chores I hate it I
hate it you're saying I'm always like
American Psycho
literally just describe
there's a routine I follow every day
every day
yeah yeah because to me when I'm doing
chores the only thing that's going to
through my mind is [ __ ] can I because
[ __ ] can I get this child can I get this
over with as fast as possible so I can
go back to doing my normal [ __ ] and it's
just it to me I hate doing chores is
because it gets me away from what I
actually want to be doing which is uh
which is what I you know but what if you
know but what if for example right like
we don't live in a perfect world where
everything you do is something that or
everything you have to do is something
that you want to do right sometimes you
know you run into those things where
you're just like you know I know I need
to do this but right now I'm just not
kind of I'm not really in the mood for
it I know I have to do it eventually but
right now you know what I don't really
like it yeah I'll distract myself and
that's it's times like that for me
personally where I'm like I can go do
the washing
because there were some instances where
I was like I would rather do the washing
right now than do this thing better well
you so you're just procrastinating
that's that's a successful progression
successful procrastination because it's
I'm replacing the thing that I have to
do with something I also have to do
anyway but I enjoy it more than what I
currently have to do
is that that's successful you are
fighting the evil with the evil is what
you're saying I'm fighting a greater
evil with a lesser evil
yeah like to me I if I'm going to do
chores there needs to be an indicator
there needs to be a line for me to be
like okay God you need to drop what
you're doing and do the chores otherwise
I'm not gonna do it unfortunately but
where does that line lie for you
bro
the line for you is all of my pants
smell like [ __ ] yes that is the line for
me wait but so do you do the laundry
then out of you in Sydney or is it well
mostly it's Sydney but when I'm with
when I'm by myself which you know now
that we've been traveling so often I've
had I've had to do laundry more often
than you know before before I was living
with Sydney that I had the same system
in place uh because Sydney Sydney likes
doing the laundry
um I much prefer hoovering up and see I
hate hoovering up I hate I hate
vacuuming hoovering up I don't enjoy it
that's why I bought a Rumba I don't know
I don't enjoy it but it's way more
satisfying because when you get that
line and you see the crumbs all gone
you're like yeah yeah I'm doing this
right I eat a lot of food
sometimes the dust builds up especially
on tiled floors because my house is
tired floors the tiles shows the dirt
yeah you can you can really really
[ __ ] see all the dust and all the
little things that build up right and
it's just instant satisfaction laundry
you have to [ __ ] wait you know you
have to put all the [ __ ] in laundry you
have to wait for it to dry and then it
gets crisp and everything like that with
vacuuming it's just like oh this is just
instantly satisfault isn't isn't your
laundry machine next year like shower or
bath yes well then when I when I like
when when it's like laundry day I just
when I'm about to go in the bath it's
like full or whatever I just take off my
clothes put them in the thing press
laundry and then one by the time I'm out
of the bathtub it's done no because what
I what I because one I don't take baths
I take showers yes yes I know I know but
the reason I hate laundry is not putting
it in it's because I always [ __ ]
forget to take it out yeah ADHD problems
right I always put in and I'm like I'm
gonna come back in an hour come back
eight hours later I've got to do laundry
again because all these clothes smell
yeah and then repeat that cycle
basically I'm very I guess I'm lucky
that I'm literally like two feet away
from my thing so when it when I'm
working I hear
and I'm like oh yeah all right also my
mine my laundry machine it washes and
then dries automatically I'm not that
really I'm not that privileged yeah see
because I had the same problem with my
old washing machine where it's like I
would throw it in and then I'd be like
I'll come back an hour later and then be
like the end of the day and I'm like oh
good I have to do this again I hate how
dryers make your clothes feel though
yeah I don't like Dr I don't like using
the dryer actually because it just makes
it all crinkly pull out I pull out my
t-shirt and it's something like a
[ __ ] tissue yeah like a [ __ ] tissue
it's like I could snap it in half well
no that's why you got to use like fabric
softeners yeah yeah and then I also like
ironing as well so
what yeah I was going to say I was I'm
literally bottomed here I was literally
about to say on the chore tier list I
thought we would all agree that ironing
is like [ __ ] down there that's like
Zeds here no I like iron sometimes I
wish I was just like [ __ ] here
sometimes I wish I was like a box just
so I could [ __ ] instantly like I get
all the creases out of my clothes oh
there is though have you seen those
things what what like I think it's like
Panasonic or like Fujitsu or something
they've like made these like uh what do
we have so much dust on the sets so much
dust where's it coming from someone
needs to Hoover up man
yeah I I also saw that as well but like
I think it's like fujito Panasonic now
have these like uh there's like these
like electric cabinets where you
it looks like if you try to Rebrand the
Iron Maiden into like something it looks
like it looks like a tiny sauna like a
tiny one-room sauna but you hang up your
clothes oh yeah this one is where you
can like put your body in it yeah yeah
stuff like that and it's like I I
legitimately thought about this thing at
top uh it's it's something like that but
it's like a full-on like like is it loud
It's my height is it loud I don't know
I've only ever seen it yeah dude yeah no
because I like I only iron if I need to
iron like t-shirts you don't need to
[ __ ] iron tea no no no no no no but
you know like I have you know when you
want to wear like a nice looking shirt
or something that's when you need to
iron it because that's when the crease
is really really show yeah I [ __ ]
hate it I always I always iron my shirts
just before I go out oh basically yeah
well you know the the Japanese business
suits that they make a lot of like
non-iron ones what do you mean they're
like ones you don't need to iron oh yeah
yeah they're like not increase but you
can there's still creases on them I've
had them I've had them I don't know like
when I'm wearing a suit you're you're
making a commitment wearing a suit shirt
and a guy like it needs to look good I
know you're wearing suits not often
which is why I don't iron
yeah yeah yeah I don't know what what do
you like about lining I think it's the
worst one I like ironing because it's
like I can just like kind of chill and
like not think while I'm doing it like
you know there's like a lot of people
who like you know do the dishes while
they watch TV and stuff like that or
yeah so like to me yeah like I don't
have to do it because I have a
dishwasher but like for me seriously
other people yeah other people not me I
used to have to do that at my old place
when I didn't have a dishwasher but like
for me now that's been replaced with
like ironing where it's just like I
don't have to think about it and also
you know it's like I get to make the
clothes I like wearing look better than
before so it's like I don't know I don't
know I I never used to like ironing
until recently I think right because it
now I just appreciate it you're speed
running speed running middle age yeah
because like I think it's like now I
appreciate when my clothes look good
yeah because I remember when I was a kid
you know I always hated doing the chores
yeah and my parents were like you'll get
to an age where you appreciate it you'll
get to an age yeah
yeah you know at first they were telling
me stories oh you know when your cousin
went to University that's when you
started enjoying cleaning that's when he
became a clean for you because he lived
with a bunch of University students that
made him really want to clean and they
were waiting went through the university
stage didn't change I was like don't
worry when you get a job and you live by
yourself that's when you appreciate it
because then you have to do it yeah live
by myself got a job didn't [ __ ] do it
and they were like well was your house
just like a mess huh was your house just
like the worst place on Earth it wasn't
like it wasn't the worst place on Earth
it was just I never enjoyed doing it so
I would only do it if railroad yeah oh
so they said you would you would enjoy
it they said I would appreciate it and
started appreciate me
like like you're throwing your clothes
into the washing machine just stand
there be like damn because I appreciate
that they did it or I I think they
thought my quality standards would be a
lot higher than what they are they
thought that I would want to iron my
shirts every week right and uh want to
you know do the washing and clean up and
every week and I'm like I'll do it when
I I have like with all my chores I have
a certain threshold where I need to do
it otherwise it actually looks like a
[ __ ] dump and my threshold my
threshold to do my chores is like here
their threshold to do chores is like up
there right you know and they thought
that as I got older my threshold would
slowly slowly slowly catch up catch up
but as I've got older it's just stayed
exactly the same